hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour
you know me i'm perry you know my
wonderful co-host hayley and i hope you
know
who simon barrett is because simon's
here celebrating
his future directorial debut but
i i mean we're going to be home here all
day if i start rattling off titles but
i feel like our audience is probably
very familiar with
i don't know let's go with your next and
the guest at the very least
yeah there actually really is what i
usually do
how how is life right now
how how is it wait now i'm really
curious because we were talking about
that
mask thing pre-rolling what what's the
mask collection like
if you're enjoying you know adding that
to the uh the fashion accessories
oh i have a bunch of really like nice
masks and i have a bunch of really
strong opinions on uh like masks uh mass
designers and stuff i actually uh
i was up in uh toronto earlier this year
filming a segment of a vhs 94
and like one of the few things i bought
there was i bought a bunch of masks
because they had really
i i thought they had really cool
fashionable masks like all these
boutiques in canada they're they're more
in it for the long haul up there i think
um you see less disposable ones and more
like
hand knit ones and you know i i'm just
like
i i absolutely would go outside with a
bucket over my head
if i could which has like again nothing
to do with like health concerns and
everything to do with just like
how i feel about the world and people
looking at me um
so so yeah i've got some really i mean
we can get into it later in the show
i've got some great really fashionable
masks and as for how everything's doing
that that pretty much summed it up uh
life is surreal for everyone right now
um and
you know my surreal thing is that i have
a film coming out
you're you're bringing you're bringing
the entertainment to people when they
need it most and the cool thing about
seance is
it's going to get a little of everything
it's going to be
in theaters on demand and digital on may
21st so
as we start to open up and get back out
in the world you have the option of
seeing this movie on the big screen but
if you'd rather stay home for a little
while longer or if you're not there yet
then you could watch it at home as well
so giving everybody the best of both
worlds
yeah which actually is kind of nice
because like i feel like every time i
have a film come out
like it it receives a small enough
release that there's like someone in
like
you know peoria who's just insanely
pissed off at me and thinks that like i
particularly like avoided their city
with like the release of the guest and
you know and the best is also like half
those people you're like it
already played in your city it's gone
now it was a failure you missed it
um and those are gratifying messages to
send to people
um no i'm actually thrilled that like it
because it does have that like hey
if you if you if you i i strongly
encourage
uh and in fact think it should be
legally mandated for every
uh american citizen to see saints in a
theater at least once
uh however um it is really nice that
it's on vod and
anyone can watch at any time and uh and
both versions should look pretty nice
even though uh we made this film we
finished this one at pandemic and i
ultimately
had to color grade it on the ipad that
i'm talking to you on right now
impressive yay well yeah i
i guess we'll see how people feel about
the film but yeah
but i i think so yeah so i think i think
haley and i wanted to hit a little bit
of everything
leading up to your feature directorial
debut haley you want to take it first
oh you you're curveballing me um
sure i was uh to prep for this i was
watching some of your chat you did at
fantasia last year
which was very insightful and i found
some of the the things you had to say
about like why you
were glad you went to film school but
why you wouldn't
recommend it necessarily now very
interesting so
what do you think is like the defining
factor on why it's no longer
as helpful as it was for you all right
yeah
great question i mean first of all i
just want to point out that like i
i like that you uh focused on
how useless and inactionable my uh
advice is to people
because i i always feel like people you
know uh
it's a strange thing because of course i
i don't feel
like i've achieved any you know like
like stature of success in my career i
you know i don't feel like i have any
safety net i think if you know
if seance doesn't do well you know i'll
have to pack my bags and hitchhike home
but i know the reality of that is not
that that's true that i actually have
like like made a few films and that i'm
doing fine
um and and so you know but i'm always
confused when people ask me for advice
because it's like hey man
i'm barely hanging in there like you
know
you don't want to ask me about anything
um but but they do
and and i think especially because you
know adam and i especially at an early
kind of phase of our group we were
pretty forthcoming about um
you know we were on social media and
stuff and i think we were pretty
forthcoming about feeling like we were
kind of outsiders
you know adam being from alabama and and
myself being from mid-missouri
you know uh kind of feeling like we you
know we would make jokes a lot about how
we kind of felt like we were
fairly low on the indie horror totem
pole
um so to speak if that's i don't know if
that's a phrase that
has aged well i'll have to examine that
one actually
um yeah sorry um
but uh but yeah i think um i think you
know we kind of felt like we were
at a low level of things compared to
some of our peers
and so whenever i get asked for advice
you know there's this just kind of like
you know uh impostor syndrome moment of
just like why
why why you don't want to really ask me
anything uh
that and the film school thing is a
pretty good example because i did go to
film school
and furthermore like my connection to
having a career now
is directly from film school which is uh
you know i wrote a film called dead
birds
because i couldn't figure out how to
direct a movie for no money so
whereas writing them was quite cheap um
i could just do it on my computer at
home
in my apartment i was living in new york
at the time with a roommate and
and so uh i thought i could make that
movie for very cheap sent it to a friend
of mine from film school who was working
at a studio
and you know there was a lot of
convoluted steps to that but basically
that's how that film got financed and
made
and on the set of that movie is how i
met adam wingard and we became friends
and
that then we have you know just because
he was making homesick in alabama at the
same time and so now we have careers and
it's like
i have no idea what my path to that
would be
if there wasn't that film school step
and that's the main reason people go to
film schools because they are looking at
a road ahead of them
and the you know the idea on the horizon
is this notion of having
a career or you know a successful uh
you know kind of just successful
position as an artist uh
you know in america and and it's this
you know everyone knows it's a very
difficult thing to you know to
actually have a career as a filmmaker
you know you're extremely unlikely to do
it especially if your
parents weren't successful at it
themselves um
and so you know i i think
film school is you know the thing that
most people are gonna immediately go to
because it feels like there's a
structured path
that gets you further towards that goal
i think increasingly that's an illusion
because of the way films are being made
now
it it you know it's just so different
and and because of the
increased costs of college um you know
to me i just don't see how anyone can
justify
going to film school like and spending
their money
doing that as opposed to just taking the
same amount of
money and trying to make a film which is
you know the same thing robert rodriguez
was saying of course you know when i was
contemplating going to film school and i
was like well that's great advice buddy
you know you found a way to do that i
don't have any friends i'm going to film
school
so you know so so there's no the problem
is there's no real magic bullet for like
film career advice you know or
screenwriting advice you know
everyone who really you know everyone
who asked me advice really just wants me
to probably say
like like let me read your script this
is amazing you know i'll give this to
you know will smith tomorrow
he'll get it made and say well you know
i can't these are not people that i know
like if i want to get a film if i want
to get my own movies made like science
it takes me like
it took me like four or five years to
find the financing for seance which is a
fairly small movie
um quite a small movie by most standards
and you know and so you know there's
always that that element but it's it's
you know it's it's tricky because career
advice is so specific to
individual people and what those people
can achieve and their individual
circumstances
that you know i tried to stay away from
it but the film school one is the big
one that people are always
asking it's like hey here's this huge
investment of my money and time do you
think i should do it
and you know the answer is probably not
it seems probably like a bad idea but if
you don't have any other ideas yeah it's
probably a good idea
and that's you know that's what anyone's
going to say i mean i did not
get i felt like anything out of my film
school education other than that
connection that
indirectly led to me having a successful
career and doing this interview right
now
so i feel like a complete hypocrite
telling people not to go to film school
and i feel like a lot of filmmakers do
this sort of thing too which is they
succeed one route
and then they immediately denounce that
round um
i i'm disinclined to do that but at the
same time
i i would strongly encourage people uh
if you are gonna go to film school just
understand
that that's not actually going to give
you anything and you still need to be
doing
all the filmmaking stuff yourself
because like you know
it you know i mean like it's what you
make of it get good grades
obviously i i i'm incapable of that
myself i just mean like you need to make
movies also
because film school's not going to teach
you how to do that
and so as someone who went to school
that's probably one of the most
realistic answers
that i've heard about the whole process
because
it can teeter one way or the other and i
don't know
it almost feels like a toss-up and
especially when you bring up the rise of
costs of those programs now especially
during a time where
you know in some senses it does seem
like the cost of making a movie
could go down if you know what
directions to turn in and what resources
to use
the cost of making a film have
absolutely gone down in my lifetime
because you know
at the time that i started making movies
everything was still essentially shot on
film
and the complexity and cost of just
shooting on film
alone you know is is when you get to the
micro budget level you know very
prohibitive
obviously filmmakers have done it uh you
know primer films like that but
like you know i don't really know how to
like
create a bullex camera out of my own
hands so i wouldn't be one of those
people that could make that affordable
you know just the fact that we have you
know the the camera technology you know
in our hands now to
to make you know these movies is so
different from what i was growing up and
you know that's
something that's been commented on a lot
i don't know i have anything really new
to say to that conversation you know
it's it's the
it's it's you know it's it depends on
your route and it depends on the film
school too
i went to you know a film school that
was not in los angeles you know but
maybe if i went to usc or afi or nyu or
one of these
you know elite schools i'd have had a
different experience i suspect i'd just
be a lot more broke and a lot more
resentful
but you know it's it was to use to say i
mean
i work with a lot of people who went to
these schools you know so somehow that
did get them a position in the film
industry
which felt like something that was not
you know instantly attainable to me so
you know there's something there might
be something there but also you know but
it's it's uh
but i mean these schools cost this they
they have to compete with one another so
like
we know that like all these colleges
have like billions and like savings and
weird weird amounts like
like you know stockpiled but they all
none of them can start charging less
than the others because then that makes
them look
worse i think so it's this escalation
where like
you know columbia university can't
charge that much less than like nyu
because that's their brand it's like
rembrandt toothpaste
in the 80s it's like it's like seven
dollars for a tiny little tube it must
do something
but it probably doesn't it makes
absolutely no sense when you phrase it
that way and that's probably very
accurate you did carve your own path
though
and from my limited perspective it seems
like you're doing wonderful things and
have uh
your feet on solid ground right now but
going back to what you mentioned about
first meeting adam
when you met him on that set what was
the thing that made you say like
like this guy like we're in line we have
similar creative sensibilities and we
gotta stick together
there's somewhat of a simple answer that
question which is um and it's
ironic now because we're working on face
off too but it was talking about john
woo
um you know again this was 2003 and you
know
it's not like john woo wasn't a
tremendously known factor he'd already
for example done face-off and uh and a
few other films
um i think paycheck was was right behind
him
and um you know but but uh you know kind
of talking
when i first met adam wingard it was
with a friend of ours also
uh evan uh evan el katz the two of them
were on
came to the set of dead birds to do an
article for fangoria about dead birds
but they were also directing their own
horror movie uh
adam was directing evan was a writer
homesick which they were shooting on 16
millimeter
while we were shooting dead birds on 35
so we were the big production
which was like the last time i was the
big production in a town
um and and so but it was really they
came to set
you know and you know with fangoria the
way you used to do this
back in the day and probably probably
it's still maybe done this way but if
you knew you were getting a set visit
from fangoria you'd save
you'd schedule for your big gore set
piece right so then they could say oh
this movie's crazy
um you know this is like bride of
reanimator meets you know times a
million
you know and you know show you the one
gore shot from the movie which it turns
out isn't in the movie and then you see
the film and you're like oh that's
that's doesn't
look terrible and and uh you know
and this was like a very you know this
this really set things off with adam on
the right way because
you know it's just awful it was cold it
was you know we're sitting out at the
monitor waiting for this gore effect to
work and then you know it's like four in
the morning and this poor woman
is lying there her name is donna brazile
this actor
and um and this like prosthetic kind of
like
lurches out of this fake body that we
built for it looked absolute rubbish it
looked so bad
and and like the director alex turner
just kind of sighed and
walked back to set and i was just like
there it was this is fangoria and they
were just like
well how long is it going to take them
to do like another one i was like oh
it's going to take a long time
and so we just ended up like chatting
because you know setting up the effect
took so long and we started talking
about john woo
and just kind of what our favorite films
were and and um
you know again at that time you know if
you it was one thing to be able to see
like the killer or a better tomorrow but
if you'd seen like a better 1202
or once a thief um you know that meant
you were kind of hardcore that meant you
like had these weird mislabeled vhs
tapes and stuff and
adam immediately kind of started talking
about uh you know
bull in the head various cuts of bullet
in the head and and i was like okay this
is the guy who knows his
weird esoteric action cinema and you
know and that was really it
and uh we we just kind of stayed in
touch and you know
in the three of us i mean that's the
funny thing is i'm awful i'm often asked
just about adam but you know we're still
friends with evan
um we're still you know we still hang
out with him all the time too and he's
still doing
some cool stuff too um you know it was a
very kind of fun night for the three of
us to meet
um but yeah it was really john woo and
then and then all of our careers family
yeah that helped too that actually was
the real bonding thing as our careers
failed
after that yeah because it's because
dead birds just didn't do well and
homesick didn't do well and then no one
wanted to hire any of us and i was
trying to get hired to do [ __ ] like
uh toy soldiers too which was like the
lowest point in my career
as i was trying to pitch for like toy
soldiers too and it turned out that like
the guy who had even got a green lit
like had accidentally he'd been thinking
of uh red dawn
um and he'd gotten them confused so he
like pitched it at a meeting and like
his boss was like yeah
yeah let's do that let's do that but it
turned out like the executive was
thinking of red dawn and it got me
confused so it's like
turns out this is like uh some kids in a
boarding school and so i was pitching
for like stuff like that
like the direct-to-video sequels to like
these movies that like i didn't really
like very much to begin with
and not getting hired because you know i
i'm sure
i would have done a terrible job i
haven't thought about toy soldiers and
god knows how long
yeah i mean i wish i honestly if it
wasn't for like if it wasn't for like
that just being one of like the the
worst pitching experience like
like worst pitching experiences i've
ever had where like the executives were
like literally nodding off in the room
while i was like
desperately trying to pitch to like you
know to keep myself financially afloat
it was really like that because that was
just like the moment where i was like
you know it's that feeling where you're
like desperately trying to get hired for
a job you don't even want really
um you know and all this sounds like oh
you know like it's a ridiculous thing to
complain about considering you know how
and i've worked a lot of shitty jobs and
i know that you know there's a lot worse
things than writing toy soldiers too
but it was one of these like it was just
the realization that i wasn't going to
make it going that route really
that i was not ever going to be like a
for hire studio guy and i just didn't
have it in me and uh
you know if i was going to succeed in
the film industry at all i kind of just
had to work outside of it
um you know and that was really i think
adam was having the same epiphany around
the same time because he was pitching
for basically the same projects he was
pitching to direct them instead of write
them which is
slightly more dignified in the industry
but not much um
and you know and so yeah we were just
like well what can we
what can we do you know and that was
really that was kind of the real drive
it's not even so much anything else
there's just a sense that like
this was just a person who had to make
movies like me and we didn't have any
other options for like happiness or
success
and so we were willing to do like
desperate things uh like make movies for
no money
and uh yeah not a lot of people are
going to do that and still to this day
that kind of guides us i mean like we
just prioritize
our work over almost everything in our
lives you know
this is kind of a non-linear tangent but
before we started recording you're
talking about how you're you're kind of
into zoom
lifestyle and you like the you like that
engagement
style better have you been pitching more
over zoom and do you think that it like
makes you more comfortable that way
well the only thing i've pitched really
over
zoom and it's it's debatable how
successful this was
is is face off two and on one hand
it's probably my most successful pitch
ever and that it's the first time i
think i've ever pitched anything and it
did well but we pitched it for like a
year and a half
and like and ultimately i think they
hired adam and i to just like
write a treatment for it initially
because just to try to understand what
we were talking about
um because our pitches were so confusing
and we were trying to like figure out
how to get like visual references for
them
so people could just keep track of the
characters and understand what we were
talking about
and that was when the studio finally
threw in the towel and was just like
look we'll give you guys a little bit of
money to just explain this on paper
like so uh so on one hand my most
successful pitch ever i kept pitching
and i kept pitching so badly that they
were forced to hire me
uh to write something down so they could
understand what my pitch had been
and then they were like oh yeah you
should take this to
we're going to script we're going to
save this to the end but now that we're
bringing up face off uh
i mean i have to ask especially now that
you've brought up the fact that he was
he he's such a revered filmmaker between
you and adam how do you find the balance
between
making a face-off movie that's your own
but maybe you know respecting the 90s
action charm of the original
well i mean you know that's just it i
mean i think um
i think uh i think that's the challenge
um
you know is is to do that i don't have
an easy solution
other than to be aware of the challenge
with every creative choice you make
you know you constantly have to be
saying is this face off
and is this what a fan of faceoff wants
and just because i'm a fan of face off
and this is what i want the blair witch
lesson doesn't mean it's the right
choice
because sometimes i have weird instincts
but maybe that's good so that's the uh
that's that's the process you have to
make
uh with that i mean you know it's it's
true
films have changed uh quite a lot since
the face-off era
um where you know our blockbusters were
essentially kind of r-rated films for
adults
right like you know that's that's very
different now you know movies now
uh you know for a film to cost as much
as face-off cost back then it has to
kind of not only appeal now to a wider
age range but more internationally
which um studios i think are still kind
of wrapping their heads around precisely
what that means
and you know i think our attitude is
like
we don't want to second-guess the
audience or anything you know we just
have a really interesting very specific
idea of what a face-off sequel should be
but you know i mean like i don't think
we'd make it if it's not rated for
example
um you know there's certain things
adam's already kind of come out and said
like like i'm not doing it if it's not
you know done a certain way
and one of those you know is i think
like we would not there's no version of
face off two that's like a pg-13 film
so it's like certain things like that
it's like you have to you can compromise
on obviously certain things but
ultimately
no one wants a pg-13 face-off sequel
right
like but at a studio level they might
for some reason think that's not true
because it might make them a lot more
money if
you know if kids for some reason are
suddenly into face-off which they're not
um so you know you have to kind of have
these like you have to go with your gut
a lot of times and just say like like
you know what is what is the version
this one that would justify its
existence
is really what you're doing you know
because i'm i understand why people are
so cynical about remakes
and sequels and you know and you know
like if we had made our i saw the devil
it would have forced every person to
clarify which i saw the devil they're
referring to in conversation
forever and you know that can be you
know you can always be like no not the
american one the original korean one you
know i can that can be annoying
especially if you
as a fan have like a concrete like
emotional
relationship with these films you know
obviously you know fan culture
and this affects the horror genre less
than most i think perhaps happily but
you know a lot of people's egos
and self identities are really tied up
in their entertainment consumption
these things are really linked to
identity in a lot of ways especially on
the internet
and you know you can say like well
you're just consuming corporate
entertainment you shouldn't really like
base your your ego and identity around
that but whatever i mean
i do it like we all do it you know like
we're fans
you know and and and and these are the
things that shape us you know the
i'm i'm is much influenced by the
fictional characters
in my life who i grew up with as a kid
you know than like some of my teachers
and stuff because you know that it was
how i found my moral compass um i'm not
gonna say you know like
you know that like ash in the evil dead
films is a great role model for a human
being
you know but it's like that's the kind
of stuff that like can can can
have an impact on you so if i you know
for example was going to make
another evil dead film there are a lot
of people who are really going to be
like well why
you know how do you justify that like
how are you not just going to ruin this
thing
that is you know a personal thing for me
um face off you know the good news about
face-off is
it's not like anyone was going to make
this movie like we we
we pitched it it's it's our idea um
you know it's not like anyone was going
to make a different version of it so so
you know we are approaching this with
like a lot of creative love but you do
just have to trust yourself at a certain
point because
i think if we second guess our creative
choices too much i think that's kind of
what led
us to blair witch you know was kind of
thinking like well our weird choices
are too weird and people don't like them
uh face-off two i think we have to say
you know the the first movie is born of
all these incredible weird choices
and i mean john wu is the greatest right
but like
face-off is to me as much john travolta
and nicholas cage
and an amazing script you know that
as it is john woo it's it's all these
factors just came together and it's
unclear
moment moment who's kidding you know but
it's the funniest move ever made but it
never tells you a joke
it never wastes your time to laugh at
what it's doing
and that to me is the beauty of 90s
action and and what we'd love to get
back to and if anything
i think perry you kind of touched on
something that like uh
i i tried to specifically do in my own
work which is i like a lot of humor but
i don't like a lot of jokes
i like things being funny but i don't
like wasting people's time
with like riffing or banter
i say this having talked continuously
for something like 17 minutes right now
but uh but but face-off is in some ways
i think um
you know there's a reason that movie is
so important to adam and me is because
it kind of does
symbolize our creative uh ideology in a
weird way which is this movie that
on one hand you know you could look at
it and say like that's the dumbest
silliest biggest bloated action
entertainment ever
but it's doing some things that are
really quite clever and brilliant you
know and and
certainly nothing that movie is doing is
easy um
and you know and so i think like you
know there's an artistry
in in entertainment that i think
sometimes gets overlooked i think it's
easy for critics to
watch a film that's clearly not trying
to be entertaining and give it the
benefit of the doubt
you know oh maybe this is doing
something artistic and i just missed it
because it's clearly not trying to be
fun
so i better you know give it at least a
three and a half um
whereas if a movie is just trying to be
entertaining and is bad then you can
kind of you can kind of be like oh
you're
you're just a bad movie aren't you
you're not trying to just you're not
trying to say anything that i might have
missed
you know maybe the fact that all my
other critic friends you know gave you a
good review
you know doesn't matter um you know
there's there's other considerations if
a movie's just trying to be
silly but if a movie is trying to be
serious then you might be like well
everyone else like this
maybe i missed something so you know
with faceoff you can love it or hate it
it's obviously a ridiculous film but i
think there is something interesting
about like entertainment as
art that that is sometimes overlooked
because
you know these things are kind of seen
as divided and i think our film
community there's some things like
product
for consumption and then it's
entertainment or it's where it's kind of
you know more high-minded and you know
we try to blend these things with kind
of
corporate activism which is a whole
other topic so
generally i just think that kind of is
what should guide a good face-off
sequel to bring it back is don't waste
people's time
and entertain them that's where i was
going with all that for sure
well i'm curious you brought up your i
saw the devil project which
you guys were on for a while and
it's another one of those films
obviously it's much more recent but
deeply beloved and celebrated and i'm
curious like when you're approaching
these
films that you love so much and you've
you've talked
uh with a very self-deprecating manner
uh
where do you find your like
where do you find it in you to be like
yeah i can pick up the mantle from john
woo i can
remake i saw the devil yeah well you
know that's a great question but uh
because you would you would you would
assume there's a tension between those
two things but that's
that's what you just said is is the key
to being a filmmaker
which is you have to have 100 confidence
with zero percent self-satisfaction uh
to be a good filmmaker
like every single time i have to be like
this is the best script i've ever
written they
ever written and uh and i'm gonna send
this off and uh
surely my oscar will be arriving shortly
and then as soon as it's off i'm like uh
well you know maybe the next one will be
decent
you know and and that's the process it's
it's kind of you have to have
in the moment you're like you almost
have to have
the project itself kind of tell you what
it is and guide you and just like in the
moment you have to
have the confidence to make decisions i
think the reason um
you know people love filmmakers like
claire denis and david lynch so much is
because it feels like they're always
operating from that instinctive space
it feels like they're always making
choices from that space of like i don't
really know why this makes literal sense
but it makes sense on like
an emotional abstract level and it does
and somehow you get it and those are the
kind of the choices as a director that
you want to be finding
um so you know so you have to have total
confidence in yourself i
genuinely have a lot of belief that i'm
good at what i do
and that i'm a talented filmmaker i
there's a lot of evidence that not
everyone agrees with me though and i
would be really foolish to discount that
and uh and furthermore you know you just
never be
like patting yourselves on the back and
celebrating because
because really what it is success all
success buys in the film industry
if if you're very lucky is the ability
to make another film and
like the work is its own reward and if
the work isn't it's a word for you then
you're doing this for the wrong reasons
and you need to get absolutely out of my
way in everyone else's way like
you know um and i'm sure i'm in a lot of
people's way
you know and so like you know and then
that's it it's like if you don't
like like you have to love filmmaking
you can't just love this notion of being
a filmmaker whatever that is
you know and and i do love what i do
like i love
making movies and i love telling stories
and i love you know the process
and sound mixing and editing and setting
up shots and lighting and stuff i love
all that and i feel like i'm good at it
but you know i i would be totally stupid
to
not stop and just be like oh i did
everything wrong well next time i'll do
it great like
and that's how i feel about like seance
is like i did a commentary attack for
science where i really tried to
specifically just talk about
what i felt like what my mistakes were i
was a little high so i don't think it's
very good
but i couldn't think of anything else to
do because i had to record it in my
apartment by myself and
i knew it was gonna be weird because i
wouldn't have adam with me i should have
made evan or adam come over and just
be my moderator but it was it was kind
of during the midst of coving
and it seemed hard to arrange so i just
did it by myself
and uh and i tried to make it like a
like hey i'm not gonna talk about like
the things i did right and things that
went well i'm gonna focus on what i feel
like i missed
um because i just thought that was kind
of a more interesting approach because i
don't hear directors do that
like i was like i messed this up i
should have i should have got a close-up
there
you know and and uh you know and i think
that's
the way to grow as an artist so you know
on one hand you could say like how do
you have like the hubris
to consider remaking something like i
saw the devil or doing a sequel to
the blair witch project or face off but
that's that's totally
unrelated to my own insecurities as a
human being that's that's like my
that's like as an artist that's a whole
different process i don't even think
about whether i'm good or not i just
think about like oh
i actually do have a new version of i
saw the devil that i could do you know
in that case like you know
we kind of did reach out to kim ji woon
indirectly at an early stage and kind of
got his blessing in particular to do
something different with i saw the devil
um which then subsequently we didn't
make so that was a real
that's how we dodged the bullet on that
one um you know blair witch uh
we uh you know we plowed right into that
uh painting of the tunnel on the wall
but you know i mean every film is
different and you know face up to
happens you know i think at the end of
the day
the fact that we're not remaking it the
fact that we're doing a sequel and the
fact that we're approaching it with you
know this true love
of fans you know i think that does guide
you in the right place
but you know you can't pander to fans
you can't it's a tricky thing you can't
second-guess what you think people want
you you really do just have to
find those characters in the story and
just hope that it guides you in right
place
wait are you staying on this topic so i
gotta go to blair witch no i just wanted
well we were going the same direction i
just wanted him to know that he's
talking to two big blair witch defenders
so wait jumping off of that i i have a i
have a question about that because
i i really i really do like that movie
and i think you both deserved a lot more
credit than
you got for it but i was one of those
people who had the luxury of seeing it
at san diego comic-con when it was
called the woods and nobody knew it was
a blair witch movie and
i loved the movie and when i realized
what it was my mind was blown i think
that event had the intended effect on me
but do you think prematurely revealing
that it was a blair witch movie
kind of you know changed the
expectations for
the folks going into it on opening
weekend
well i certainly don't feel like we did
everything right
my dog's having an aneurism that'll
that'll definitely happen at least one
more time
um yeah well i mean okay
the the ultimate revelation of blair
witch which you know i could obviously
unpack
quite a lot um but the short version is
we made a film in secret that
it turned out we made for about 300
people uh you're one of them
um you know like like i think one of the
last times i talked to you was actually
when i was doing press for blair witch
and
our friend john schnepp rest in peace uh
he was also a big supporter of the film
and you know and and so hearing from
people like yourself and and
and john and you know people who you
know i i know creatively are
people i agree with and i think their
opinions are cool you know
it's easy to kind of i think get what
that movie was trying to do
if you know our sensibility and you're a
horror fan in a specific way
um ultimately though we're kind of
hardcore people
like like we like there's a reason you
do this show
and it's because you watch like
everything um
and i follow you so i know you watch
everything and
ultimately a lot of people are just sick
of found footage
a lot of people did not like like a lot
of people still don't like the original
blair witch project and are still mad
about it and they don't want a sequel
and all the people who do love blue
ridge project also didn't want a sequel
and they have very complicated feelings
about the previous one
so we were just like we were kind of in
this like little niche
market of like people that wanted a very
sincere sequel to the 1999 film the
blair witch project
and because we made it in secret we
never stopped to ask if anyone
liked this idea or wanted this or wanted
or thought like what we were doing was a
good idea
a lot of filmmakers talk very negatively
about the process of audience testing in
hollywood and obviously that's um
that's because it can often be used to
push an agenda right
you know we think of audience testing as
the way movies are made
you know are dumbed down and taken away
from their creators but audience testing
is great
because you know any director who
doesn't any director who doesn't want to
know how people are going to react to
their film
i think is making a huge mistake and i
don't care if you think those people are
smart
or educated cinephiles or not like
they're they're your audience
so blair witch is a film that if we had
tested it at an early stage
conceptually i think a lot of red flags
would have come up
and we would have realized oh people
don't understand that we're not
for example saying that we're directly
showing the witch
and by the way our credits are
misleading which we didn't realize
either
so like you know so there was a lot of
things about making a movie in secrecy
that handicap you creatively in ways
that you wouldn't perceive at the time
because you're making movie in secrecy
and you're not talking to anyone else
and everyone you're talking to has been
working on blair witch for like last
several years
and you've started speaking basically
your own weird language
of references at that point and so you
don't ever think when you're like i mean
there were times there were there was a
moment specifically in the edit room for
blair witch
where i remember adam cut something out
of the movie and i was like yeah we
should cut that
it's boring and it was like this crucial
little bit of information that then a
bunch of people flagged as like a
confusing thing
but we were just so bored of looking at
it you know and we hadn't had any
input from anyone else so you know so
that's that's honestly like
i think the larger answer of how making
that in secrecy i think hurt the film
is because we did not understand the the
feedback in advance of the audience that
we're making the film for
you know it's in hindsight it's
impossible to say what people wanted the
woods
which is what lionsgate was calling that
film prior to calling it blair witch i
didn't like that title either because i
could only forget the lucky mckee movie
um and and like you know
i think a lot of people were hoping adam
and i were doing an original horror
movie
and you know we didn't realize that like
we kind of
looked at your next and the guest and
what we perceived as their failure
at uh and it's not our perception that
they both failed at the box office
that's that's pretty much mathematical
uh mathematically provable
um so we were looking at those as not
things to be
repeated or imitated it was only kind of
when i made
when i wrote blair witch and i realized
that like actually people
did like the weird thing we were doing
they just didn't want to necessarily pay
money to see the theaters
that i was like aha seance
so i have that was something i really
wanted to ask about the guest has had
such an interesting journey
from coming out being very beloved by a
smaller audience
then being discovered years later on
streaming and developing a much larger
audience
what has it been like to have a project
go through that and i know adam recently
mentioned the possibility of a series is
it still like
this eight year old film still a living
thing
you know it is in a way i mean we are
working on a
another guest thing uh which is kind of
all i'll say about that
but um but like you know i i don't
i don't know it's tricky i think it's a
huge mistake actually
for film makers to make sequels to films
that have developed an audience and the
reason for that is that i think you
cannot exceed the expectations of what
people are building up in their minds
um and and you should realize how
fortunate you are
if you're a filmmaker and you have a
cult success like the guest i mean
it's tremendously gratifying i i was
actually just
recently talking uh with someone about
the guest and and how
specifically we didn't feel like that
movie was any kind of success at the
time
even critically i know it was
well reviewed in like a rotten tomatoes
way but none of those reviews a lot of
those reviews felt to us like the three
out of fives
like like like like critics kind of
being like it's not too annoying like
positive you know but but but you know
no one was really saying like oh this is
this like
unique thing and and these filmmakers
have uh you know a particularly strange
sense of humor clearly and
you know you know no one was really
identifying that until streaming when
people were kind of like oh this is
actually quite funny
um and and you know it's great to have
that happen
it's it's incredibly gratifying i i
actually would ideally skip the failure
at the beginning
and go straight to the success in the
future if i could um
but you know better better you know late
than never as as they say
and um and to a certain extent i think
this is and this is where i think you
really need to be careful
if you're in kind of the position that
we're in which is not to
you don't want to exploit or fetishize a
genuine fandom that's evolved in an
organic nice way which is what we kind
of have with the guest which is
i think people like the guest more
because they know it's a failure
in other words i think we have pat the
passionate fandom
of fans who know that their fandom is
unique um
i i know by the way i'm aware i'm well
aware that people are somehow able to
skip the cognitive dissonance
and have that for like my hero academia
and marvel movies now
nonetheless there's a specific fandom as
you both know
to when you feel like you are the
world's like kind of biggest fan of
something
not everyone else likes it not everyone
else knows what you're talking about
when you recommend the guests to people
still probably 19 out of 20 of them are
like i have no idea what you're talking
about and then if you show it to them
you know 19 out of 20 people will say
well why have you wasted my time
um but that one out of 20 person is is
really quite passionate and
and so that's what we have the guest is
i think people like it more because you
can go on like
you know a box office website and be
like oh wow they're not joking
this was really quite a failure um you
know by any
level of assessment and and you know and
i think there's a feeling on adam's in
my part that we want to
you know give fans of the movie
something but i think at this point like
a guest sequel
would just disappoint everyone because
everyone has a different idea in their
head of what that would be just like the
your next sequel
that we mistakenly kind of talked about
when we
were under the impression that people
might want that to exist
you know it's it's this notion where
like if we actually made that now
everyone would just be disappointed by
the reality of it um and then like 10
years later someone be like oh that
wasn't so bad
and uh ideally i'd like to stop doing
that but you know i mean
the the truth is i would never
intentionally you can't you can't
you can't intentionally try to make a
movie with a success
you know narrative like the guest you
really have to
be i think a genuinely strange filmmaker
you know like adam and like myself and
have a really
strange idea that you mistakenly think
is going to be a huge success
which is what we thought the guest was
going to be we thought this was like our
like
you know like hurt locker times the
terminator times halloween you know
um and and and you really have to make
kind of a weird movie that that people
don't like at the time and then like
years later it's a strange thing i would
never
try to second guess it but i do think
you know we're very cautious about
like like there's a lot of people that
are like please make a guest sequel
and you have to like you have to like
you want to just like take them and look
them in the eye and just say
you don't actually want that you'd be
very annoyed with me if i did that
because i'm not going to do what you
think i'm going to do
i'm going to do something weird and
annoying and you're going to be annoyed
by it like it's not going to have dan in
it if i make a guest sequel
or he'll show up at the end and he'll be
like working in a library or something
because like the character of david will
have completely assimilated assimilated
correctly into society
and is like perfectly happy now and is
like running for mayor somewhere
and it would be like a totally
unsatisfying film for me because
the weird sensibility that led me to
write the guest in the first place
still guides all my creative decisions
which means
you know when i work in that space i
think people aren't gonna like it
um but we do have like this notion of of
kind of
giving people more of something that
they might enjoy
in a way that hopefully doesn't feel
like we're you know
exploiting any kind of fandom with all
that in mind in terms of release success
how did you apply all those lessons
learned to
seance and i i guess day one when you
put pen to paper so to speak what were
your intentions as far as how that movie
was going to connect to the audience
that you were eventually going to reach
again
uh well the the honest answer in and i'm
dead serious is i knew i probably
wouldn't connect with audiences again
because i i i so i knew i had to make
the movie cheaper
than the guest because i knew that your
next was perceived as being very
successful despite the fact that it also
wasn't really welcomed by mainstream
audiences
uh but that's because we made it for a
lot less than we made the guest for so i
knew i kind of needed to be
a little closer to your next than the
guest and then i could get away with
doing something weird again
um you know i also um you know i don't
really
think i'm a good horror writer or
director
um i i used to think i was good at it
but now i think i'm i'm not
actually and um and this is because i
just
know i see so many people who are so
much better at it than i am
um and and and you know
i mean i could name so many horror films
that came out last year that like i was
just like i wouldn't know how to do this
um you know relic possessor you know and
there's like there's people who really
know how to set up a scare
um and and and really you know get like
take you to a different world and for me
like well possesses sci-fi that's that's
different i shouldn't compare myself to
possessor brandon's on a different
different wavelength uh with his stuff
but um but you know it
i i don't think i i want to get back to
that thought because i i don't think i'm
a good horror filmmaker in like a
traditional sense i don't necessarily
think i have good horror ideas uh
but i have a lot of love for the genre
and and so with seance
i kind of thought you know i should go
for something that's more horror or
adjacent i should go for something
that's more horror friendly than uh than
the guests
because the guest is just this weird
combination of genres
and i kind of thought you know if my
foundation for seance
obviously i'm going to end up throwing a
bunch of genres into this thing i just
can't help myself
um you know suki's in a western like
everyone's in a different movie
um but but you know like like but i knew
the foundation
like i was like if my foundation is i
take this kind of 90 slash revival
and these giallos and stuff and that and
that's like my foundation
that feels commercial enough to me that
i can get pretty weird on top of it
and and that was kind of what i was
thinking is i was like well if i write
like more
a girl school you know slasher mystery
uh
you know how like how bad can it be kind
of
uh you know it was kind of what i was
thinking i was like you know it can be
fairly affordable and i can probably
get fairly weird in that and uh you know
tell a different story with different
approach to character so
that was really it i and and i was like
and it'll be in a single location
and then uh every school in winnipeg
told us to to [ __ ] off
and then i ended up having to film in a
bunch of locations and i should have
written a movie that took place in a
bunch of locations because that's what i
ended up having to do
but you know and you know we had and i
mean i knew
i knew i was gonna have fewer shooting
days to make seance than we had on your
next
or the guest you know because i knew i
was doing at union i knew i was being in
winnipeg
and i knew i had basic ensemble cast of
young actors
of varying experience ranges so i knew
what my challenges were
um but i just figured if i made everyone
look cool
and you know and again i just feel like
i just feel a lot of like
i've consumed so many slasher movies
and ghost stories and gialli
that i just was like i just don't feel
like i can mess up too badly if this is
the template i'm going for this time
but i'm never going to do that again
because because i did think it was very
difficult
it was much harder than i thought and
also like the uh
you know the the thing that seance and
you're next and the guests do which is
this
mysterious stranger slasher movie thing
that's loosely based on a john hughes
film
is so specific that that like you really
have to assume people
don't want much more of it so i think
like seance
that's it hearing winnipeg just gave me
a chill that was probably one of the
coldest shooting locations i think i've
ever been in my entire life
where i might what what brought you to
winnipeg
the the set visit for the movie run with
sarah paulson
i stood outside for a good while at
three o'clock in the morning and i've
i've truly never felt cold like that
before
yeah so we filmed seance in november and
december
um in winnipeg um i mean i i don't know
if you've had the chance to see it but
like there's there's snowy exteriors in
that movie
that are like like we had to rush to
film them because
pretty soon it was getting so cold that
it would just stop snowing
um you know just precipitation stops
happening or whatever
um and that kind of is like the you know
january february march and yeah i mean
it was jade michael um who's in hunter
hunter i just watched i like that movie
um but uh she's in seance and there's a
scene with her outdoors where she's
reacting with her phone
it was the hardest scene to shoot in the
film it was pretty much the only time
i had to like walk off set for a second
for just like a minute i just like
kareem
just like take care of this like set
this up i just need a second because i
was just so like
i don't know if we're gonna make this
movie it was like it was like the second
week and i was like we're so buying
like on everything and we weren't behind
the schedule but like we weren't getting
all the coverage i'd hoped for of course
and jade's out there with this phone and
it's so cold it was like
in terms of fahrenheit i think it was
like five below zero or something but
you know
we were using celsius i have no idea i
just knew it was like you know it was
her hands weren't working on the phone
screen because her fingers were so cold
and the phone was so cold and like
and then we're putting her in this tent
to warm her up and then taking her out
instantly into the cold again so she's
like
you know basically we're torturing her
and that was when i was like i
i this is this is a dark moment
and like i don't know what i was
thinking um
and there's there's one i think i think
i actually put it hopefully lra doesn't
get mad at me about this i think she had
to prove it hillary smith who played uh
helena in the film
there's there's one outtake that i put
in like the deleted scenes for the
for the blu-ray where she just like
walks out and sookie gives her her line
and she's just like
i'm sorry i'm so cold i'm sorry
because she just like walked out of the
building it's them walking outdoors and
she was just completely unprepared for
just like what it feels like walking out
into the winnipeg cold at night which is
it feels like you're being dropped from
about 20 feet
straight into an icy lake like it knocks
the breath out of you
um i'd walk out of the apartments where
kareem and i and the crew were staying
and
you just it would just feel like getting
like punched in the gut you're just like
you
you so you did you'd suck in air because
the feeling on your skin was so extreme
and your lungs would instantly like
freeze basically so you're like coughing
and hacking and like
trying to i mean it was like and then
you're like and you're like and then
people live here i loved it i loved it i
loved winnipeg i love the vibe i love
the fact that like
the environment itself is just like
absolutely determined to kill you
i love the cruise i mean i just love the
energy there but uh yeah it was awful
um i think i think suki said it was like
her favorite shoot ever because no one
did anything on it
because like usually people are like
socializing and hanging out and she's
she's
she's like me she's you know she's a
kind of strange introverted person
and so like she i think like was totally
down for just like like the
the hanging out on sans which i could
have told her like no one ever hangs out
on any of our productions they're not
fun
i think if you're having fun making a
movie i've never had fun making a movie
and i'm not saying like it's wrong
to have fun making a movie but if i ever
did have fun making a movie i would
seriously examine what was going on
like i'd be like like am i doing this
right or have i gotten complacent
because you shouldn't be happy you
should be like trying to make everything
perfect and it never
is and uh you know you should be
freaking out and stress puking all the
time which is what i was doing every day
and
that sounds oh yeah i mean scream
for a while i was driving kareem and i
everywhere and then kareem actually had
to talk to production and say like like
simon is not safe to drive
because i was just like so stressed out
and i'd like i had to get up and be like
walk into our car and i just like leaned
over and vomit
and then i'd be like all right we got to
do it but we just didn't have enough
money or time to make this movie and
there was no safety net you know there's
no contingency
had awesome line producer connie hoy
some great people involved who helped
make it work but um
but yeah i mean like like you know when
you're making these kind of miserable
tough films
um you know the circumstances are always
going to be awful
um but yeah filming filming a winner in
winnipeg
wow i mean but but then but it looks
great but i will say look
the actors look really cold on camera
which is what i kept saying to them
they're like it's so cold i'm like
yeah but it looks great on camera and
and you know what it does it does
because you can see their breath
you can see like they're you know their
faces are kind of flushed you can see
that it's real authentic cold that we're
not like
that we didn't just put a bunch of
styrofoam in someone's front yard
um and you know and make them wear coats
in like
you know the middle of the summer in
australia or something um we we did it
they're authentically unhappy and cold
in seance and but i mean i i i will
finish that by saying that by the end
i was convinced that the trick to
beating the cold
this is after i'd gone to mec and
dropped like
you know 500 bucks on new boots and
stuff because i thought all my winter
gear was like i was i thought i was so
ready to go and then you get up to
winnipeg you realize all your stuff
sucks
um and you need real winter clothes um
but my trick was to just never get warm
so i would just stand outside whenever
we had exteriors i would stand outside
the whole time
by myself when people would have lunch
and i would just pace and pace and pace
to stay warm and uh that was how we got
through those
uh those shoots um i felt bad for the
actors because
as soon as they would rap or as soon as
they would stop shooting they'd rush
them to this tent
and put them in this hot tent and i was
just like i just like don't go in the
tent stay out here with me
um but they didn't want to stay out here
with me they wanted to be warm
jokes on them they probably felt colder
in the long run
i feel like we got to let you go soon
through anything seance seance-wise in
before we do
before we do our last two of me
wait haley no haley you asked hayley
sorry do we have time for another
question before we do our last two
because i know we
haven't gotten yelled at in the chat yet
i am that means yes
give someone the opportunity to yell at
us i see nothing
okay then we're good okay um
actually mine's more of an industry
question that i wanted to ask you
because something else that you talked
about
in your fantasia discussion was
sort of like the the disappearing middle
class of filmmaking and you know we've
lost a lot of the home video market and
now the theatrical market is declining
and i'm just curious um
what your take is on these last few
weeks as we've seen people
really returning to theaters um in
in maybe more than i expected
well uh well first of all i should say
thank you so much for watching that i
really
do appreciate it when people do any
research at all prior to an interview it
makes things
so much better because um it's been you
know
it's not just the same kind of questions
and and we get to kind of leap to a real
conversation
um you know thank you uh i i really
appreciate that um
i'm not like an industry industry
prognosticator that anyone should take
seriously but you know i do
i i think the thing that's interesting
about theaters will be to see
if people come back from movies that
aren't godzilla versus kong
um is there going to be a theatrical
market for non-blockbusters
um the the kind of nobodies of the world
which was filming
actually in winnipeg when we were doing
seance um they left uh
well we were still filming um but um you
know like like movies like that
and and and whether people are willing
to see those in theaters i don't know
you know i mean
it's certainly the profitability
of these films is getting smaller you
know uh during the dvd era
you know anything that you know you
could put a star on the cover of would
make
15 20 million just in overseas disc
sales for these studios
and you know and that led to very bad
cinema by and large
when the profit margins get smaller
cinema i think gets better
personally because i think filmmakers
are just kind of hungrier and more
interesting and
and you know the climate is just kind of
more
like you know it's more garnered towards
films that are unique and actually good
you know like word of mouth starts to
matter more
i don't really know you know if people
are going to come back to theaters in a
major way i certainly hope they do i
certainly will be i'm already
like you know seeing everything i can in
theaters um because i love doing it but
again i know that i'm
kind of in the in the minority there i
think to me the more interesting
conversation is what's going to happen
with streaming
and particularly horror uh the horror
genre when it comes to streaming
because we have shutter and we have no
one else
and i think with the bigger streaming
services now hulu are willing to spend
some money on horror they're doing david
bruckner's hellraiser reboot that's
exciting
but i think for the netflix's you know
especially after
you know their kind of controversy with
cuties and how that actually did affect
their shareholder price
there's no incentive for these streaming
services to make content that's in any
way shocking or provocative
they're very de-incentivized to do it in
fact their incentivization is is to make
fairly safe
award stuff regardless of whether or not
people watch it right because
that's kind of what gets the cultural
conversation uh
in a way that helps their shareholder
values
so that's kind of my concern is is if
the home video market which is a
relatively new thing and of course
cinema history but
horror has always gone towards the grind
houses and the drive-ins and then the
video stores
um so now we're looking at kind of a
streaming marketplace but it's one that
to me excludes a lot of
genre work that isn't just kind of hacky
uh
you know action stuff because because i
think
streaming services have no kind of
incentive to create this
kind of content now of course there are
a lot of uh films that you know
defy that i i think the best reviewed
horror from last year his house was a
netflix movie
but you know again that's a very
political film in its context at least
um and so you know so so i think i don't
know i i think
i'm curious to see you know who's gonna
be financing the next martyrs
um you know i i i i mean that's french
so i guess
french people will be financing it with
their tax money and they can just
examine that however they wish
um but you know they actually have
financing for arts there so i guess
that's not a good example
but you know what i mean it's like it's
like i i just don't know
what the market is you know for for
streaming content that's in any way
pushes the envelope in you know
in terms of kind of content and the way
that the horizon has always been known
for
so that's something to think about
because there's no real theatrical
market
for you know avant-garde horror unless
a24 is putting it out really
um and i don't know what the streaming
market is as well
so you know i'm a little interested in
that in the future of that
you know our movies you know to get the
theatrical
window do movies have to be these four
quadrant blockbusters that appeal to you
know everyone
across the globe you know and you know
or are you know or or is there going to
be a market for the smaller kind of
10 to 20 million films that ultimately
tend to be the movies that
i like um i or
am i gonna be making movies for under
you know three million dollars for this
my career
any one of these things would be
actually wonderful so
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
hope i hope everything comes back
i hope uh i hope um i hope theaters
come back but you know i i haven't seen
uh
you know a lot of studios really pushing
for that yet so you know i guess
hopefully this
this interview will be you know an
interesting kind of historical artifact
you know to whatever the next step is
for how we consume entertainment
which is probably going to involve some
chip in our eyes anyway where you'll
just like basically like look up into
the left and just like your movies will
play
in your rick retinas you know and you'll
just you know be kind of
one with your computer anyway so it'll
just be a different process then
hard to predict stuff like i am
yeah all right i did get the warning we
always
had the same two questions haley i'll
give you the honors first which would
you like to choose
well one of them we got spoiled
usually asked do you have any pets i
know that you do please tell me about
your dog
i have a uh neurotic
aggressive ill-behaved rescue dog named
hazel
um who has uh bitten two humans uh
myself and adam wingard
um both both seriously enough that you
know
we were both unhappy um uh
she she uh we adopted her
um uh my partner and i
my girlfriend kelsey and i who's
probably trying to keep her quiet
frantically right now
uh adopted her almost
two years ago when she was four we went
to like a little adoption place
and um and she was really calm
and so i was like this is great that's
what i want i want a calm kind of older
dog
she was a little overweight i was like
okay this is perfect
she is calm but she's crazy
and we can't let her around other dogs
or other people
and we can't really leave her alone and
she's kind of ruined my life
but i love her very much hazel is a very
good she's a very good
very loving dog uh when she's not biting
you
or uh attacking other dogs
but i'm now one of those people who's
constantly apologizing neurotically for
you know for their pet i'm always like
hey sorry she's a rescue dog like sorry
working on it um she's gotten a lot
better you know she's not
you know she's lost weight she's a lot
healthier she's a lot happier now her
tail wags and stuff
um and she clearly like loves being here
with us but she um
but yeah but it's it's like way way more
time than i thought and uh you know and
but uh
hazel hazel uh will surely
uh you know make an appearance in all my
social media feeds shortly because
uh she's a very photogenic dog and i
just take photos
but she's great i mean i really wanted a
rescue dog i grew up in rescue dogs my
mom
uh you know to this day kind of runs a
hospice for like like abandoned poodles
you see like she used her things she
used to go to places and adopt like
elderly poodles that like no one
would want because they were in like
decrepit health and kind of give them
another couple years so i would you know
come home and there'd be like three
elderly like a poodle that would just
like walk over and just lean against you
because it didn't have like a hip
like because i had to like lean on you
and i'd be like oh who's this and i'll
go that's
that's rafa he's probably not going to
be with us much longer i'm like
okay okay uh actually this is a this is
a true story my mom waited to euthanize
one of the dogs
until adam and i were making your necks
because we were both staying in her
house
um adam had this horrible toothache and
was taking dog morphine
that my mom gave him like his little dog
morphine capsules that had helped her
like you know take one of the dogs to
the rainbow bridge i guess basically
um you know and she always keeps these
dogs like like you know
it's like it feels a little past the
expiration date
in some cases you know because you don't
want to let go and it's the hardest
thing of having a pet right
they'll last forever and i'm sure when
hazel gets old i'm gonna
you know start looking into cloning and
stuff and you know completely turn out
to be a hypocrite but like
i mean i've seen my mom like
intravenously feeding pets and it's like
you know the dog
probably is kind of telling you it's
natural life cycle's over
but anyway that's what i grew up around
and i always thought like giving rescue
animals a home is
the right thing to do i didn't want to
you know go to a breeder or anything i
wanted to get a troubled dog that needed
a home and i got a troubled dog that
needed a home and
now is this complete like you know
walking metaphor for all my own
neuroses and anxieties and issues as a
human
your mom's a saint and she's lucky to
have you i know it's a lot but it's
worth it
all right i have a feeling we're going
to be forced to end this but i'm going
to squeeze this last question in
that i have a feeling you're going to
have a lot of answers to
our guests if they have any form any new
piece of genre storytelling that they
want to recommend to our viewership
whether it's a new movie a
show a book video game you name it
you know i i i
i actually um there's so many just
bouncing out of my head right now
um but i'm just going to go with the
first one uh that comes to mind i really
loved
a film last year that i saw called
anything for jackson
which was a low-budget canadian film uh
that's on shutter and
and i thought it was so brilliant and
and i thought it was really
i had an approach to horror storytelling
that i thought was so good
which is essentially the protagonists
are dabbling in satanism
and kind of getting over the head
they're dabbling in it for relatively
altruistic reasons
ish but but it's a it's a brilliant
approach to storytelling because it
allows your protagonists
it gives you a reason why your
protagonist would be in a scary
situation and then
the scary situation unfolds and it's
super low budget uh
but you know totally creative
um and then i'm gonna squeeze another
one in because just because i haven't
come out you know i like shouting out
movies
and there's a public movie coming out
called frankenstein um kind of in the
meet the feeble style
i got to see it i think through night
stream or possibly fantasia
i thought it was great um so keep an eye
out for frankenzed
i don't have any involvement in it i
don't know anyone involved i just
thought it was one of the best movies i
saw last year and it's
going completely under people's radar
it's a kind of frankenstein retelling
uh with puppets but it's really gory
again and that kind of meet the feebles
um
i i wish i could think of another
example but really that's kind of it for
puppet horror isn't it
anyway frankenzed and anything for
jackson would be my two recommendations
for horror fans
anything but jackson we are big fans
frankenzed is going on the list
all right yeah yeah yeah you'll dig it
we gotta let you go
so i'm gonna give everybody a reminder
simon's new movie seance it's gonna be
available
may 21st and you have the option of
seeing it in theaters
on demand digital check it out simon
congratulations it is always a delight
to see you
thank you so much for having me i really
appreciate it
you